so it's officially appetizer and
entertaining season and these spinach
and artichoke stuffed shrimp are my
go-to anyone I've ever made these for
absolutely loves them if you want to
entertain this holiday or if you're
having Seafood Christmas you got to try
these out so you're going to peel daine
and Butterfly your shrimp and then
you're going to season them with some
oil and all the spices I've listed
you'll give that a quick mix and then
you'll take some chopped spinach crab
meat which is optional chopped artichoke
some mayo breadcrumbs seasoning and some
pepper jack cheese I also like to add in
some lemon juice and zest and you have
this delicious filling you'll take your
shrimp and then you're going to go ahead
and fill it with that stuffing I like to
make a little ring in my cast iron
skillet so it looks beautiful and
halfway through I just go ahead and
drizzle some garlic Dill butter sauce on
top guys when I tell you everyone loves
these and the full recipes on my blog
enjoy